people don't want it choose a restaurant
choose a hotel choose a purchase without
doing tons of research which is fine if
you're going to tulum and choosing among
16 airbnbs but it's not fine when you
are choosing among thousands of
potential partners and so what does this
era of maximizers do they always keep
swiping saying who else is out there
logan yuri welcome to the show
thank you so much for having me i was
very excited to receive this invitation
what does being the director of
relationship science at hinge entail
you know it's really a dream job and if
i can just go off topic right from the
beginning i recently found an email
from march 29th
2012
where i emailed a guy at okcupid who i
had met in an event and i was clearly
trying to network with him and i was
like how's your move to la by the way
i'd love to work at okcupid and you know
no response totally ghosted and now i'm
like wow
10 years later and i have this job that
i've essentially been trying to get for
over a decade just feels so good and
it's also a really healthy reminder that
when you see people's careers you're
really seeing their final product the
highly edited version you don't see all
the emails that not just where they were
told no to but all the emails where they
just didn't even get a response not even
enough respect
yeah and so my job at hinge is
incredible because i basically get to
conduct research into dating and i get
to have these amazing moments where i'm
like okay what am i hearing from my
friends and my dating coaching clients
for example i'm hearing a lot about
women dating guys with lower sex drives
the guy is depressed what's going on do
they want to date the depressed guy can
they overcome the low sex drive issue
how do they support a depressed partner
certainly they want to be dating someone
who's in therapy and then i bring that
back to hinge and then we conduct
research on things like
um has talking about mental health gone
from a stigmatized topic to actually a
must-have and so we did this great
research around the end of 2021 where we
found that um
86 of people say it's really important
to them to date someone who is in
therapy and who prioritizes their mental
health and in fact people would be more
likely to go on a second date with you
if you say on the first date that you go
to therapy and so i basically get to
take topics that i'm hearing about
through my one-to-one coaching or my
friends or just being aware of the
dating zeitgeist bring it to hinge
conduct research with some amazing
researchers and then share it with the
world and say like hey this is what's
happening in dating right now are you
doing the data science for this or have
you got a team that works below youtube
to pull all of that yeah i have amazing
research collaborators um so i am really
coming in with a lot of the hypotheses
and then working closely with the
researchers and we do have some amazing
data scientists but i am not doing the
data science myself it is funny because
when i
i had met my husband in college but when
i really met him was when we were both
working at google he was a data
scientist and i was learning a data
science language called r
and i was like i'm looking for an r
tutor and he's like i just dropped out
of a phd program hello girl at the lunch
table can i tutor you in r every day and
so anyway data science and r have a very
close place in my heart but i would say
i am
i ended up being much better at being
with my husband than
writing writing his programming language
yeah so what else
if that's one of them some men with a
low libido um and the challenges that
that has in relationships men suffering
with mental health and depression what
are some of the other trends that you've
discovered over the last couple of years
sure yeah and i would say that one
wasn't that gendered it was like pretty
broad it was just like hey the last few
years have been so hard i don't know a
person who hasn't been dealing with
depression anxiety not sleeping like i
think everyone's kind of gone through
something rough so i would say more
broadly just what is happening in the
dating world with mental health and how
people are not only talking about it but
want to be talking about it um another
one that i just conducted and wrapped up
last week was about the role of asking
for advice in gen z
so
gen z as you can imagine
very anxious generation notoriously
very digital obviously so if you think
about sex in the city the tv show people
would you know the women would go to
brunch on sunday and talk to their
friends about the last guy they had sex
with well now it's like every text
message can be screenshoted every
profile can be shared
every message that you're about to send
you can ask the you know the group chat
what should i say and so it's basically
turned all these elements of dating into
this crowd source thing where you almost
have this war room and you're like okay
guys what are we writing and yeah maybe
you write a more clever text but like
the actual relationship is between you
and the person that you're dating and
when you are lying in bed with them
paying attention to how you feel that is
not something that you can outsource or
crowdsource and so the message for me
behind that research was basically
saying to gen z
you all are way too reliant on your
friends for advice
and your friends should be your
cheerleaders they should be the people
encouraging you
um helping you achieve your goals they
should not be the coach telling you what
those goals are
and so really helping gen z in
particular learn this is what it's like
to tune into how you feel this is how to
build up those muscles and actually you
need to rely on yourself because you are
the one in the relationship your your
posse is not dating that person you are
i think
one of the most interesting realizations
i've had from when i went to uni 15
years ago to now
we used to run an event called carnage
which is exactly as it sounds it was a
big bar crawl and everyone wore a
t-shirt and on the back of the t-shirt
there were different tasks that you had
to do like yeah pull a pig
snug three randoms like steal someone
else's hat you know like stuff that is
so cancelable like any one of those
would be worthy of cancellation right
now yeah um and i was having this
conversation with a friend a while ago
who used to be another franchisee like
myself when we were both 1920 and we
were talking about how we don't see this
same
sort of messy sloppy
dance floor kissing nights out that we
would have facilitated perhaps when we
started running events and he said
something that was really interesting
that was
you basically have perpetual state
surveillance that's done by gullible
volunteers
because everybody has a cctv camera in
their pocket and whereas previously you
could
make whatever catastrophic error you
wanted and the most people that could
find out about it were the friends of
your friends who they maybe were able to
tell individually over blackberry pin or
something like there was no way
to facilitate your failings
be brought being broadcast to the world
and i think that that does create even
in person forget online dating that
facilitates an in-person sort of sword
of damocles thing where everyone's just
feeling like there's something hovering
over their heads at that whole time and
it's difficult to just let yourself feel
at ease when that's happening
oh yeah i absolutely agree with that and
i hadn't thought about it in a while but
i recently spent a day with someone
who's 10 years younger than me who went
to the same university
and we were just comparing notes and
there were so many elements of her
experience that i just couldn't i just
had never thought about and so for
example having a dating app while you're
in college and really understanding does
that mean that you just
are exposed to more people at your
university than you would have been
otherwise does it mean that
everyone at your school is hooking up
with people at other schools like you
know i went to harvard and so it was
nice for harvard women to be able to
date harvard men but if harvard men are
on dating apps now you're competing with
women at the many many universities in
boston and so what does that mean for
the harvard social life and like i don't
really know and then kind of exactly
what you were talking about it's like we
had you know when i walked into college
we had
flip phones i had a cute pink flip phone
and then i got a blackberry but the
cameras were so bad and so i would have
you know a camera that i might take out
but that's really different from
obviously like live streaming or
instagram stories and yeah dance floor
makeouts are really fun part of going to
college and so we didn't she and i
didn't talk about that but it is
fascinating to think about
if there's always a part of your brain
thinking that you're being recorded what
does that do to you
and you know this idea of surveillance
or the opticon or something like that
it's like i imagine that it does change
your
psychology because
kind of as another example um i spent 24
hours last week with a reporter from the
new york times and so it's like there's
what i'm saying
and then there's the part of my brain
that's making sure that what i'm saying
is okay right and so that's like doing
double duty and i was very tired
afterwards because i was cognitively
overloaded with like what i'm saying and
making sure that it's okay and so if
your whole brain is what i'm doing and
then making sure i wouldn't be upset if
this were recorded or shared like that
just actually seems really inauthentic
and exhausting well what you're
externalizing or you're playing a
persona right every decision that you
make and everything that you say gets
run through first the filter of did i
come up with it and then secondly the
filter of is this okay for me to say oh
maybe it's not i've got to think about
it and that's not a very sort of easy
graceful way to be so what would you say
well how would you categorize the sort
of messaging that young people are being
given around what love and dating and
romance is supposed to be in 2022
yeah it's something that i'm actively
thinking about i would say 2022 is a
year where i have spent way more time
thinking about the gen z audience and so
i would say as of now i'm probably a
millennial dating expert so that means
that i've worked with loads of
millennial clients a lot of hinge users
are millennials so the research and the
data i've had access to for two years is
based on that and now it's like of
course like what happens with
generations like people age into the
dating market and so i need to spend way
more time understanding that and as
silly as it sounds i just binge watched
both seasons of euphoria i've watched
that what's that okay
it's like a really
amazing slash raunchy show on hbo
it's about a teen dealing with drug
addiction there's a lot of sex there's a
lot of nudity but it's also just kind of
about the like over stimulating
anxious
gen z high school experience and like
who knows how realistic or not that is i
certainly don't think uh the clothes are
realistic but um it is interesting to
think about like what does gen z know
about dating and so
um there are some things that are like
clear trends so of course the world is
moving in a more fluid direction and so
that means things like gender identity
gender orientation
um sexual orientation and so if you
think about that applied to dating
you're not necessarily looking for the
one or you're not necessarily as focused
on this outcome of like i'm gonna get
married i'm gonna be married to one
person and i hope it lasts as long as
possible maybe you're into non-monogamy
maybe you're into
having a relationship that's really
powerful
but you're not focused on marriage or
maybe you don't even want to have kids
maybe climate change has made you
so afraid of the future that like having
kids sounds preposterous to you and so
it's really interesting to think about
what are the cultural forces affecting
gen z and then how does that show up in
their dating
that being said
i do think that we
all really do have this natural desire
to love and be loved and so i don't care
what's happening on euphoria i don't
care how many tick tocks there are about
certain trends at the end of the day
love and dating and finding someone or
someone's i still think is very relevant
to people well yeah human biology is a
hell of a drug and you're going to have
to work incredibly hard to like front
brain out
yeah millions of years of evolution that
compels you to behave in one way i think
i
i've never felt so much like a boomer as
i have recently i'm a millennial as well
you know like slap bang in the middle of
it not even though you're great for a
boomerang
but
i've never felt so out of touch and yeah
it's crazy to look at you know remember
it wasn't that long ago that millennials
were sort of the
the media's common calling card they
were the ones that everybody was
bitching on and and now
i'm being looked at and thinking about
you know stuff to do with gender
fluidity stuff to do with non-monogamy
being not just for certain friends of
mine in austin but you know as a general
scalable yeah yeah
opportunity and i'm like this just it
doesn't resonate with me it doesn't
resonate with my friends and i now
i'm starting to get a sense of what it
must have felt like for my parents
generation
looking down at my generation just
getting into facebook and online dating
and dick pics and stuff like that to
then roll that forward so i guess each
new generation can make the older
generation feel more boomery than they
ever thought they could
totally and i feel the exact same way
where i'm like wait it feels like two
years ago there was an article about
millennials are killing dining room
furniture millennials are killing the
paper napkin it was all about how
millennials were changing things like i
have a friend who is known as the
millennial workplace expert and then
boom now all we're talking about is gen
z
and i find that so fascinating and are
you a fan of bo burnham yes i've only
seen a little bit of his work but yes
he's good
okay so i'm a massive bo burnham fan and
he has that amazing special that came
out last year called inside
and there's a song on it i play the
songs on repeat but there's a song
that's basically like he was born in
1990 and he was always known as the
young guy
and he was always like oh i can't
believe you've accomplished this by that
age and then the song about turning 30
he's like now the zoomers are telling me
that i'm out of touch
and so you're really like through these
very funny lyrics hearing about his
existential crisis about being like the
young hip cool guy pushing the edges
where very few people are going to be
like i can't believe you accomplished
that by 30 because it's like 30 is not
considered supposed to have your [ __ ]
together yeah
i had this conversation not long ago
that
just
getting
no longer being young
is a strange is a strange thing so i'm
34 and pretty much every single year
probably up until
31 or 32
everything
biologically was just improving so i was
getting better looking i was becoming
more confident i was recovering from
workouts in the gym better i had more
muscle mass i could get leaner i'd all
that stuff right everything
and then you just sort of you know when
you're at the top of a roller coaster
and it's been going on and then you
start to feel yourself go weightless and
you go oh hold hang in a second hang on
this is i know what happens next this is
just before it starts to go down and
that's something that i'm grappling with
at the moment the fact that you know my
gym workouts are going to get
progressively more difficult for me to
recover from moving forward that looking
good is going to become progressively
more difficult moving forward now i
think there's a good argument to be made
here for both guys and girls that
if you have made it into your 30s and
your primary source of value that you
see in yourself to the world is the way
that you look
there's probably something that goes
wrong there because you can have wisdom
that's just going to compound over time
grace
empathy love poise you know confident
all that stuff all of that [ __ ] can
continue to grow um but there is
something a bit sort of like oh
is the ride over like that kind of
totally when did that change happen for
you probably 31 32
um so probably during the pandemic was
or just after that within the last sort
of 18 months to two years but again
i don't know how much of that's just
been due to the fact that i've been
locked in the house you know maybe i'm
gonna have a fourth puberty or something
next year and i'm gonna like
shoot up again but i think for a good
few of my friends as well it seems to be
the same case we're just finding stuff
that used to be easy
and not getting over hangovers that's
been impossible for 10 years um
like
some things that used to be easier
just aren't the same anymore i think
that i mean it all really resonates with
me i'm also 34 and i feel like i'm less
in touch with my body and my health
as compared to my husband but my husband
is one of those people where it's like
he's he read that book how
how not to die and he
is you know he's always intermittent
fasting and he's thinking about like how
his cells can age backwards and i'm like
dude i just want to feel good when i
wake up in the morning
like i just want to feel physically
better and he's like planning for the
future so i do think it depends on how
tuned in to our own bodies we all are
well here's an interesting thing
civilization on average has never been
this old
and on average we've never had so long
to live
yeah that's so wild that blows my mind
the fact that yeah whether we're the
oldest civilization in history that's
going to live the longest oh yeah well
that also is relevant to relationships
because if you're choosing a partner for
a decade or a few decades versus many
many many decades like half a century
and how does that change your
expectations i even have friends who are
mormon and are like you're choosing that
person for forever and i'm like oh my
god i can't even fathom that amount of
pressure that you're choosing a
relationship for all of eternity bro
that literally could be 70 years from
the time that you're 20. someone goes
away does their mission comes back and
you're like okay so my assistant ben
he's mormon and uh he's
22
22 23 and him and his misses are married
and they're amazing but i'm like
[ __ ] man like that that could be you
could be talking about 70 years of
marriage from this point and this is
eternity for that
and the rest
don't underestimate that that's more
than underestimate
eternity a
good lesson so
what is it
i've been thinking about this a lot i've
had a lot of conversations on the show
to do with dating intersexual dynamics
the mating market imbalances stuff like
that one of the things that keeps coming
up is kind of a bit of an ick factor
that some people have around anybody
that has an intentional
approach toward designing a lifestyle
around dating why why do you think that
is
okay i couldn't think that that was
funnier because i'm literally drinking
from a mug that says intentionally ever
after
which is the last line of my book it's
about you know forget happily ever after
and go for intentionally ever after and
so i'm really like ready to put my
boxing gloves on and fight this one
because like this is my entire ethos
it's my perspective and
my viewpoint is that the type of clients
that i work with the people who are
drawn to my work which is not for
everyone as far as type of person it's
the person who says um
if i want to be healthy then i might
listen to
tim ferriss or i might be interested in
bulletproof coffee i would listen to
these podcasts and take these
supplements if i wanted to get better at
personal finances then i would listen to
ramit sethi like there's just like a
self-help world and so like we believe
in we these people including myself
believe in like lifestyle design and
saying like when you have a goal you
should go after it you should have
people who are experts you should
understand the blind spots you should
understand what makes it hard and then
make a plan and somehow love feels like
it's on this other dimension where we're
not allowed to do that and people put
love on a special platform and they
won't allow it to be researched or
analyzed and they think that it makes it
unromantic but my entire philosophy is
that
yes love is natural love is organic you
are born knowing how to love but you are
not born knowing how to date and dating
as we know it is extremely new in the
span of human history so even the idea
of people on their own choosing each
other that happened in around 1890 and
there's a great book on this called the
labor of love by maura weigel since then
obviously gender dynamics have changed
women being out of the house in the
workplace like this idea of the shop
girl in the 1920s you know meeting a guy
but even then it was like oh i'm going
to go on a date so i can have a hot meal
because i can't afford one otherwise and
then you think online dating started
around 94 95 with match group and
kiss.com then the dating apps only
started a decade ago so you were talking
about human biology as a hell of a drug
well you know evolutionary
evolutionarily we are not designed to
choose from thousands of potential
options and either even choose for
ourselves the historical
reference is that marriage was an
economic
institution institution where maybe
my father would give your father 12
camels for my hand in marriage and if my
land was next to your land we could
combine the two through marriage and so
the idea i'd take 12 camels for you
logan okay thank you so much that's fine
flattered the idea that people would be
marrying for love the idea that people
would be marrying for 70 years the idea
that people would be marrying for
self-actualization that's also new and
so i think that ich factor is people
responding to this idea that they want
love and dating to be a realm that
cannot be analyzed when actually i'm
like hey this is one of the most
important decisions you will make in
your life who your partner is that is
your number one teammate that is your
number one giver of advice this is your
counsel and why would you not try to
take what this amazing field of
relationship science has learned about
long-term relationships attraction what
the field of behavioral science has
learned about common biases and how we
make mistakes in decision making why
wouldn't you take all that and then be
informed to make the right decision just
like you'd think about personal finance
accounting
nutrition fitness etc this is a science
and it can be analyzed and i think the
ick factor is misplaced i think a lot of
people see romance as a black box that
there is something magical about it
there's a
term called conceptual inertia which i
learned about from a history of science
research which is that um when
new insights from science arrive a lot
of the time it takes time for culture to
then catch up so if you went from a
earth being the center of the universe
to the earth revolving around the sun
revolving around the galaxy
that switch in terms of models was
accepted by signs but only 50 years 75
years later was sort of permeated the
culture so that people actually started
to think and feel like that so you have
this sort of lagging measure of what
people think despite the fact that they
may have had something proven in front
of them and i think that
insights from evolutionary psychology
from relationship science all this stuff
takes time to trickle down and what
you're battling against is still a lot
of
culture disney vacation of movies you
love actually rom-coms
that
kind of i mean
is relationship science romantic it's
certainly not romantic in the
traditional way so you're not it's very
rare that you're going to have here's a
movie about a girl who optimized her
online dating profile and after she'd
done that then she decided to go on 37
dates and then pick the next best person
that was there after that because she'd
read algorithms still love them to live
by and you go that's just not going to
be a movie
so a lot of the time
with regards to relationships and
presented in common media you don't have
what's optimal being what's shown you
have kind of this idealized much more
naturalistic way so i do think there's a
tension between those two
everything you just said i agree with
and i think you really nailed the
problem and then i can present my
approach which is slightly different and
i think the cultural inertia thing is
that what is called cultural inertia
yeah that makes total sense to me i mean
even if i'm thinking about like climate
change and don't look up and like why is
it so hard for you know everyone is
paying attention to this thing in pop
culture
versus what's happening with climate
change and it's like why are we not
paying attention to the science and i
don't know but yes in my world i would
say first of all what do i think is
romantic what i think is romantic is
waking up in bed with my husband after
we've been together for seven years and
just being excited to talk feeling like
your partner is your best friend and
it's you against the world like still
being excited to have sex and have
dinner with someone who you've known for
a long time and there is no chase
because essentially you are a team and
there is such a foundation of trust
romance to me is the experience i had
over the last two years with my husband
which is he was diagnosed with a rare
form of bone cancer he went through 18
rounds of chemotherapy below the knee
ampu leg amputation crazy [ __ ] that you
do not expect in year one of marriage
and saying i [ __ ] love you i'm here
for you
i
you are much more than your body to me
you are much more than your health to me
and just being like i'm all in like to
me that is the essence of romance i
don't think romance is oh um he planned
this date where he picked me up in an
uber black and took me to a cool
expensive sushi restaurant like i don't
care like that is courtship courtship is
lovely flirting is lovely feeling a
connection with someone is lovely but to
me the real romance is the deep
connection and trust that you maintain
over time
so people who are resisting this they're
basically saying when you apply science
to love you are taking us out of the
black box you are taking us away from
the mystery and you are really focusing
on the practical but life is the
practical life is doing your taxes life
is wiping your baby's diaper like that's
what life is like it's not the trip to
hawaii it's not those moments because
yes those are peak moments but most of
life is the average moment where you and
this person are saying i'm your partner
and i'm all in and let's do this
together and so
yes disney movies are the way they are
rom-coms are the way they are i like the
show bridgerton but like what i'm really
doing what my
role in the universe is right now is to
help people find a long-term partner
that is going to help them create a
great life it's not about the reality tv
show
sparky
in the moment feeling because that fades
and i'm really here for the long-term
relationships
i wonder how much of the black box
mentality is also because
if people believe that there is a
effective strategy to be able to date
that makes them more culpable for their
dating failures
like if it hasn't gone well and it's a
black box then there was nothing that i
could have done about it but if it
hasn't gone well and it's because i
wasn't sufficiently well educated or
informed or i maybe i messed up then
it's not to do with the magic of cupid
it's to do with me not knowing enough
that's a very hot take and i i think
that's clever and i will think about it
more but my gut reaction is that people
already feel that way and so i have a
chapter in my book called why dating is
harder now than ever before one of the
elements of that is that in the past if
your love was negotiated not your love
your marriage was negotiated for you by
your father by the matchmaker
and camels can't forget the camels then
everything was really written for you
right we we inherited these identities
so for me if i had been born 200 years
before let's say i would have been a
jewish woman living in berlin
who knew exactly how i spent my time my
marriage would have been negotiated for
me by the local matchmaker i would have
known what i ate what i wore how i spent
shabbat how i raised my children
everything would have been predetermined
for me and part of modern life is
freedom but that freedom is scary
because when you write your own story if
that story sucks you are the only one to
blame and i think that is the ethos of
our modern era and so
i already think that people think i
haven't found love it's on me i don't
think that you know as much as people
like romance i don't think that they
imagine cupid just missed his arrow i
really think that if you saw the emails
that i get you'd know people are being
extremely hard on themselves and they
are taking their lack of success and
love as a personal failure so we're
already there
how can people learn to be happy with
their decisions then getting into and
getting out of relationships and all of
the things they're in
without it being about a single
incident what is an overarching way to
make better decisions or to be happier
with your decisions
yeah so we talked about how i have this
intentionally ever after mug and i
really do believe in this intentional
approach to love and so what that might
look like and there's a whole menu of
things and people can pick and choose
what works for them but a lot of it is
just owning your past behavior and so in
my class date smarter we do this
activity called the relationship audit
and people have a lot of resistance to
it they don't necessarily
enjoy it but you basically say who are
the people i've dated why did it end
what was good about this relationship
what was bad what side of me did they
bring out
you know if they understand attachment
theory then was that person person
anxious or avoidant or secure so really
saying what's gone on in my past and
then
looking at your patterns and saying wow
i tend to
meet more people in person maybe the
dating apps aren't a good fit for me
that's a takeaway or
i tend to like someone until they like
me back and then i don't trust them and
i run away or my version of love is
chasing after someone and so a lot of it
is understanding what's your past
behavior and how can you make different
choices in the future
then there's understanding
what matters and what doesn't for
long-term relationship success and so
some of the things that matter less than
people think they do
are things like looks and money
yes hot people are great
rich people are great sure but whatever
you have you adapt to it over time and
so the feeling of being wealthy is
something that you get used to and it
doesn't impact your life as much as you
think people also overestimate having
the same personality or having the same
interests those matter but they're not
actually huge factors the things that do
matter are things like
loyalty kindness
someone who's emotionally stable
a person who you can fight well with yes
fight well because fighting is
inevitable
somebody who you can make hard decisions
with and then what's really become the
most important one to me which is what
side of you that person brings out
because i don't care about their resume
i don't care about what's on paper
who are you when you are with them
because that's who you'll be for a lot
of your life
one of the conversations we've had a lot
on the show recently has been to do with
the asymmetries in the dating market
that increasingly women are out earning
men they're out educating men and you
have an ever increasing group of high
performing women competing for an ever
decreasing group of ultra high
performing turbo chads at the top
given the fact that you've identified
there that looks money a lot of the
status markers that typically are either
utilized commercialized weaponized by
dating apps and online dating
aren't necessarily the things that
predict long-term relationship success
how would you advise girls to try and
overcome their
uh innate hypergamy their desire to date
up and across to find the dude with the
six figure income that's six foot tall
with a six
inch whatever
yeah i mean there are so many
interesting historical things here that
i can pull from including just one
example i remember
i went to a talk a few years ago where
the guy was talking about how like
historically most doctors have been men
and men would marry their nurses and now
actually a lot of male doctors marry
female doctors and so what does that
even mean in terms of like intermingling
of classes and things like that but yes
the number one piece of advice that i
would give women is
forget about height
i think that setting height filters just
really blocks many people from seeing
amazing people and so yes when there's a
height filter you might feel tempted to
say okay i'd like to date a guy who's at
least six feet tall and then you make
your height minimum six feet tall and
what you may not realize is that only
fourteen percent of the american male
population is six feet or taller and
only three point nine percent of the
american male population is six three or
taller and so they're just thinking like
yes that would be nice but they don't
realize these filters are acting as
bouncers where people under that height
are not even making it into your club or
the people that you can meet and so
there is really no evidence that height
impacts long-term relationship success
and in fact i think that um maybe my
hottest take here would be date the
least attractive person who you're
attracted to
because you're still attracted to that
person you're caring less about what
other people think and you are really
maybe finding that hidden gem and that's
a lot of the work that i do with people
it's not settling settling is this
curse word the s word that people are so
afraid of i'm not about settling i'm
about saying what are the things that
matter and really go after those and
what are the things that don't and don't
be distracted by them can you explain
the difference between maximizing and
satisficing when it comes to decision
making
yeah so there's been amazing research
done by
barry schwartz and he has a great book
called the paradox of choice where he
talks about these two different ways of
making decisions so maximizing is that
you believe that you want to turn over
every stone you want to really do all
the research and you want to keep
looking and looking and looking until
you find the perfect solution
satisficing is saying i'm going to set a
bar and maybe that bar is really high
but once i achieve what i was looking
for with that bar i'm going to be
excited about it and stop looking and so
for example if you are looking for an
espresso machine at home the maximizer
might read the wire cutter reviews they
might read consumer reports they might
go to 10 different shops and then they
finally decide on getting the revel
at-home espresso machine but even when
they are drinking it they might think to
themselves
it is a little bitter i should have
gotten this other one i made a mistake
and there's this sense of you're never
done there could always be something
better out there whereas the satisficer
might say okay nespresso is a good brand
i will go to the downtown nespresso
store i will buy the one that is in my
price range and that the
sales person recommends and then i will
go home and feel good about it and so
the maximizers believe that they are
getting the objective best result
because of their research whereas the
satisficer is the one who's actually
happy because in the end it's not about
making the right decision it's about how
you feel about your decision and the
maximizers are never satisfied and the
satisficer is able to say i got what i
wanted and i feel good about it how does
this manifest in dating
this is a huge problem in modern dating
where our culture generally is very
focused on maximizers and so people
don't want to choose a restaurant
choose a hotel
um
choose a purchase without doing tons of
research right we are the google yelp
tripadvisor generation which is fine if
you're going to tulum and choosing among
16 airbnbs but it's not fine when you
are choosing among thousands of
potential partners and so what does this
era of maximizers do they always keep
swiping thinking their perfect person is
one swipe away and what a satisficer
does is they say i want someone who i'm
attracted to
who would fit in well with my family
who's kind and loyal and who i enjoy
talking to and when they find that
person whatever their requirements are
they say i found this person they're
great i'm going to invest in the
relationship and they don't sit there
saying who else is out there and my
proverbial coaching couch is full of
people who are maximizers saying
my girlfriend wants me to propose i
really like her but she's just not
interested in abstract ideas and
couldn't i just be with someone who
likes trail running a little bit more
and they are imagining that they could
come up with this frankenstein person
and then that's their perfect partner
instead of saying something like i'm
really excited about the person that i
found and i am going to build the
relationship of my dreams as opposed to
finding the perfect partner
you have three dating tendencies one of
which is the maximizer can you lay out
the rest of that framework for everyone
yeah absolutely so as i was writing my
book i really like frameworks i really
like recognizing trends and patterns i
feel like that's sort of what my brain
does well and i was like all right i've
talked to all these people
i you know some of them are older some
of them are younger different countries
what do they have in common it felt like
this theme was unrealistic expectations
and so the framework is one the
romanticizer the person who has
unrealistic expectations of
relationships who expects that it's
going to be
butterflies there's a soulmate for them
it'll always be easy
that they'll know it when they see it
and really it's this concept of once the
relationship starts to feel hard they
think oh this can't be my soul mate
because it would be effortless with them
the second one is the maximizer which
we've just talked about unrealistic
expectations of their partner they
expect that they're going to find this
perfect partner and then everything will
work out as opposed to investing in the
relationship and then the third one
which has become a much larger group
during the pandemic is the hesitator
they have unrealistic expectations of
themselves and they think i'm just not
lovable yet i'm just not ready i need to
be
i need to lose weight i need a more
impressive job title i need to clean my
apartment then i'll be ready and so they
have this imaginary date in their mind
or
moment in their mind will they'll be
ready to date when the truth is no one's
ever 100 ready for anything and in fact
the only way to get better at dating is
by dating the only way to figure out who
you want to be with is by trying on
different people and relationships and
seeing what works and sitting at home
reading a dating book or thinking about
how you might eventually start working
out doesn't get you any closer to
finding your person let's say that
someone has identified themselves as one
of those three
what's your advice for overcoming that
tendency for each of those categories
yeah so for the romanticizer these are
often the people who cry when i talk to
them because they're like you want me to
give up my love story you're telling me
i have to settle and i'm like no i'm
trying to reconfigure in your mind what
matters and what doesn't so the work i
do with those people is around
giving up on the soul mate there's so
many people out there who could work for
you you can write
a life story or a love story with many
people also understanding that who cares
about the we met people are so few
focused on this idea of the meat cute
right like we met at the farmer's market
or he switched he switched his seat on
the plane and we sat next to each other
and talked for six hours it's like who
cares if you're gonna be married for 50
years then the day you met is point zero
zero five five percent of your total
relationship and so really taking away
the disney rom-com
hugh grant moments and saying like
what's romantic is this these are the
things that matter let's get you into a
relationship and help you
really focus on the things that matter
and the things that don't
for the maximizer some of it is just
understanding what satisficing might
look like
and so you made kind of a cheeky
reference to this before but yes there
is this idea of the secretary problem
which is this idea that the
mathematically correct answer to hiring
a secretary is that you go through a
third of the possible candidates you say
who is the best person from that group
that's your benchmark person and the
next time that you find someone who you
like as much or more than them you hire
them so you basically say who's out
there i've identified the best of that
and then you identify then you um
go after the next person who matches
your benchmark so that you don't waste
too much time looking but you don't stop
too early and so for the maximizer it's
about understanding yeah of course you
want to find someone great but it's also
what you bring to the relationship how
you build it together so stop spending
so much time researching and find
someone great and build with them and
then for the hesitator and i think this
is a group that i have had a lot of
success with
during the pandemic it's saying to them
stop hesitating and start dating and
let's make a deadline for you let's
choose a few outfits for your dates
let's help you get more comfortable
maybe you've gained some weight during
the pandemic maybe it's been a while
that's fine let's actually help you just
get out there and get your sea legs back
because sitting at home thinking about
how you should date just feels
frustrating and so for the hesitator
it's really about how can we create
action so that you move towards having
the identity of being a dater
are any of your
tendencies related to attachment styles
yeah i've definitely found that there's
some overlap i've also found that
maximizers can be
um avoidant attached so one of the
common things with people who have an
avoidant attachment style is that they
are looking for excuses to push people
away
i talk about my book a woman whose
boyfriend wanted to break up with her
because she pronounced the word picture
like a picture on the wall as pitcher
like a pitcher of water
and so it's like really that's what
you're gonna break up with someone for
and in his mind he turned it into this
big thing about education and class and
how articulate she was and how could the
mother of my children pronounce it
picture and it's like dude there's
something else going on that is not
about the word picture but you are so
focusing on this and maximizing about it
as an avoidant strategy and so i've
definitely seen that i think that many
people who have the romanticizer
tendencies can be anxiously attached
because their vision of love might be
that
um kind of the rom-com
500 days of summer thing where it's love
is the chase love is convincing somebody
to be with you as opposed to love is two
people choosing each other and so i'd
say i haven't done a one-to-one analysis
and in fact in my class the first
session is what's your dating tendency
and what's your attachment style and i
do have a lot of anxiously attached
maximizers who take my class but
in general i think that people come with
a whole load of nuanced family
background genetics histories etc and
that they can be kind of more
complicated than just one of these types
i feel like i would be doing a
disservice to everybody to not ask
someone that works behind the wall at
hinge about how to design an online
dating profile what's the
biggest do's and don'ts and wins and
losses sure yeah i i love this topic i'm
super comfortable speaking to it so yeah
so
my perspective on a profile is that it's
really storytelling
and what is the story that you are
trying to communicate and so when i work
with clients i start by saying to them
what are the top three things that you
want to communicate with your profile so
for someone it might be i'm from boston
i love cooking and family is really
important to me and i'm saying great
okay let's make sure we get those points
across then make sure that you're
choosing
photos and prompt responses that really
support that and so you don't want to
repeat you know i love the red sox over
and over again but i want to i want to
at least see that represented in one
another important thing that we found
through hinge research is the importance
of variety so
sometimes i'll see a profile and it's a
guy wearing a pair of sunglasses taking
selfies in front of different monuments
around the world i'm like dude we get it
you travel but i don't see more of you
and so i want
a
first photo that's kind of like a
headshot where i see your face clearly
no filters no sunglasses
i want at least one photo that's a full
body people have that question so you
might as well show it some activity
photos seeing you do something that you
love candids work really well and then
also at least one photo with family and
friends show us that you have a social
life but not one where you and your ten
mates are playing rugby and i don't know
which one of you are and i have to play
where's wally with you
and so really that should be clear and
then for the prompt responses
sometimes people try to be clever and
say you know
um
certain things like i'm you know what
i'm competitive about then they write
everything and it's like no we want to
see more information about you that's
actually a cliche so you want to ignore
it and so really using your prompt
responses as a way to communicate who
are you what are you looking for what
makes you different
and remember that your profile is like a
t-shirt that you wear into a bar
whatever you wear people will respond to
and so if you wear a shirt with madonna
on it you're going to have a different
conversation than if you wear a shirt
with a game of thrones character and
they're going to lead to different
conversations different types of people
and so
most people would benefit from being
more
intentional about their profile and even
if their profile is great if you're
bored of online dating switch it up
because it will lead to new
conversations did i hear you say that
mirror selfies gym selfies and smoking
are three big no-nos as well yeah
exactly yeah definitely
um no smoking nothing too controversial
that'll turn people off the gym selfie
it just does not perform well selfies
there are some exceptions to that
especially i feel like some women know
how to take really good selfies and they
know their angles but in general those
are not the high performers you want to
go for high quality photos where it's
clear what you look like if you have a
friend with a good camera or portrait
mode
you know go to the beach at
golden hour and have your friend make
you laugh and take a picture of you
laughing like
show me what it looks like to be with
you and date you that is so much better
than some
poorly lit gym selfie where i'm just
like oh another
another one of those what about good and
bad practices for online dating
beyond the
first front window
yeah you know it depends on what the
person's needs are so i work with some
people who are way too picky and our
work together is helping them be less
picky or less picky about the things
that don't matter sometimes i work with
people who need to be more picky they go
on way too many dates with people who
are not interesting or are not
interested in them and so there's an
element of kind of which category do you
tend to fall into but let's just say
that people
are being too picky i would say
open it up your filters be willing to
date someone who's farther away
be open to dating someone who's a little
older a little younger than you might
have and expand your height filters
i would also say that when you are using
the app sometimes people swipe as if
would i marry this person or not and it
should be something like would i be
willing to have a conversation with this
person or not and so for those who are
too picky it's just being more flexible
in the early stages because you don't
know who's even going to convert into a
match for people who are not picky
enough i would say how can you have
higher standards around who you go on a
date with and so um
some people i call zq zero questions
this is often men who just ask no
questions so it's like they're willing
to be kind of interviewed but they don't
say and what about you and what about
you and so i have women who say to me
after the date i could have written his
biography but
he didn't ask me a single question about
myself and when i asked these zq men
what they're doing they're like well she
had something to say she could have
spoken up or i just thought she thought
i was so interesting it's like no dude
good conversation is we are taking turns
talking and you show interest in me and
you ask follow-up questions and so
that's just kind of a general point that
um people should certainly be making
statements sharing about themselves and
then asking questions so that it feels
like a conversation not an interview
is it true that on average if you have a
conversation where somebody asks more
questions they tend to come across more
likeable than somebody that makes the
same number but of statements
yeah there's really great research on
this it basically shows that the more
questions you ask and the less time you
spend talking the more that person
thinks you're a great conversationalist
because essentially what you're tapping
into is people like talking about
themselves people like to be made to
feel as if they are fascinating and so
like right now you've been asking me
questions for an hour i feel great i'm
like wow you know chris is so curious
about me and i must be so interesting
even though like of course we're in a
dynamic where this is the setup you're
asking me questions but it feels really
good and so think about that and apply
it to dating it's much more important to
be interested showing interest in the
person than to be interesting and so
when i have people who say to me i
haven't been on a trip in two years and
nothing's going on in my life i'm not
interesting how could i date i'm like
you are at an advantage it doesn't
matter just go out there and ask deep
questions flirt with people
be vulnerable
be curious use a support response where
you ask deeper questions about what's
going on for them as opposed to a shift
response where you bring the
conversation back to you and this person
will think that you are endlessly
fascinating i suppose it's difficult if
you and somebody else who's also taken
the same red pill about how to have
conversations in dates that's just going
to end up with you going like what about
you no no no no what about you
so yeah that could i could imagine that
coming to a stalemate
yeah yeah in my dating class we do a lot
of
live demos and i actually did one last
week where i made this mistake where i
was trying to show how to ask good
questions but i wasn't letting the
person ask me questions back so it
really just felt like i was
interrogating them and then two students
did it and i was like thank goodness you
went because they actually took turns
asking responding going deeper and so it
should not have a feeling of like one
person is the podcast interviewer and
the other one is the guest you also have
to share
you talk about the spark and you've got
a problem with the spark what's up with
that
yeah the spark is
that moment where you feel instant
chemistry you feel fireworks you feel
like the whole world has stopped except
for you and this person and the spark is
definitely real i have certainly felt
the spark with people throughout my life
the issue with it and why i think it's a
really big problem in modern dating is
that people are overly optimizing for it
and so my clients would say things to me
like
this one guy jonathan would say i met
this guy he was great we had a good
conversation he planned a fun date i'm
not going to see him again and when i'd
say why he'd say i just didn't feel the
spark and so he was going on dates
expecting to have this magical moment
and so yes the spark is real but we also
expect to have it too often and so
there's research that only 11 percent of
people experience love at first sight
i would also say that because of the
mere exposure effect we often like
things more over time as we're more
exposed to them so it's why we might
like a person who lives in our apartment
building who we see every day or you
might even like a song the more that you
hear it and so the spark can grow over
time
people
are sometimes just very sparky some
people are really good looking they're
really charismatic that can also be tied
to narcissism and so certain people give
everyone the spark but you think it's
something special with you
and finally the third issue is that the
spark doesn't mean that you have a
long-term lasting connection and many
divorced couples or unhappily married
couples started with the spark and so
it's enough to kind of get you off the
ground but not to keep going and so my
entire advice my antidote to this is to
go after the slow burn
which is the person who might not spark
with you on the first date but the more
you go out with them the more you like
them over time the more you peel back
the layers and you realize how funny or
curious or
brilliant they are
and a lot of people have passed them by
because they're not sparky but you could
wind up with this amazing engaging
partner because you were willing to give
them that second look
i think that's one of the most
interesting insights that i've taken
from the stuff that you've done which is
that
the spark can be something systemic
about a person and not unique to your
interaction with them and this makes
sense right i've had tons of
conversations about narcissism and dark
triad traits and stuff like that and
those individuals
they are sparking the
guy at the grocery store they are
sparking the bus driver that you know
that's just
part of their existence
and
using that as a proxy for there is
something exciting about this meaning
there is something that has long-term
longevity it's just a leap that's being
made way too much and i think again as
well you're seeing
one of the problems of culture taking a
hold of one very particular element and
then just myopically focusing on it and
saying well this is something that's
really really important and you look at
every rom-com movie throughout time well
actually no that's a lie that i'm i'm
incorrect there there are rom-com movies
where the good
guy that's kind of the hapless romantic
that's chasing the girl
she does sometimes end up with with him
um but
there is also a lot of push toward the
spark given that it happens whatever 11
percent of the time it's definitely not
only in 11 of rom-com movies
totally yeah absolutely and so this kind
of goes back to the point you made
earlier chris which is like what is
making it into the movies and it's like
most movies and there are a few
exceptions like the before trilogy most
movies are very focused on
the meet cute okay she's so clumsy
he's too focused on work and then they
go through trials and tribulations and
then they end up together but where the
movie ends is them coming together as a
couple and then it's the famous three
words right they lived happily ever
after but the movie ends at their coming
together it doesn't tell you what's
going on you're 12 into the marriage
when their kid is having trouble at
school and they haven't had sex in a
year and all of this stuff and so our
movies are selling us on the on the
happily ever after early stage not the
long-term relationship success and this
idea of the spark
after having written my book and talked
talking to a lot of people about it like
i totally notice it out and about like
if i go to a party or a conference
everyone will kind of be talking about
the same person oh did you meet so and
so oh so-and-so's presentation was so
great it's like yeah that person's
really sparky and everyone here is drawn
to them and often they're very
conventionally attractive or they make
great eye contact with you or they do
that thing where they make you feel
interesting bill clinton
yeah the bill clinton-style thing
exactly right you feel like you're the
only person in the room and it's like
yes that person is very sparky we are
all feeling a spark with that person
that doesn't mean anything for like who
we should all be with and so just
knowing that that spark sensation is
real but understanding that it's more
representative of that person than your
dynamic i think does really help you
move past it that's a huge red pill
that's really really interesting i think
as well
one of the things that i find so
attractive in a relationship is when i
admire my partner like if i admire the
girl that i'm with then it's such a
compelling um
pull of attraction toward them
however
anybody that has a spark
is
admirable because you look at them and
you think oh god you know everybody else
wants them you've got this sort of
crowd-sourced sense of the toys in the
playground type thing
charisma generally extroversion
generally you know likeability humor all
that stuff that we've talked about um so
yeah decoupling those is
is really interesting and i think asking
yourself the question of seriously is
this person just like this with
everybody or is this person specifically
like this because of me is probably a
good one to ask i think since this is
personal to you we could like even zoom
in on it a little bit more which is do
you know this concept of the halo effect
yes which is people that are good
looking tend on average to be treated
better by everyone in society right and
like i know that i do this all the time
i mean people even do this with good
looking babies
our whole lives if you are good looking
people ascribe positive traits to you oh
she's good luck looking she must be
generous she must be kind she might must
be smart and compassionate so part of
what you're describing is the halo
effect of
when somebody is good looking we ascribe
all these other traits to them the other
thing that you're talking about
the admiring your partner yes that is
huge and i think people should be
thinking about that more so maybe for
you or for anyone else who's
experiencing this it's saying when i
think about admiring someone i want to
admire them because i can learn from
them because they have a passion because
they have pursued their dreams and
really being concrete around what this
admiration is versus this more
nebulous halo effect admiration which is
everyone else seems to want them so i
should want them to it's almost more of
the
um market dynamics or evolutionary
biology piece it's not actually about
admiration it's saying well if everyone
else values them clearly they are of
value
what's the difference between sliding
and deciding through a relationship
yeah so there's great research on how
people make decisions in relationships
and a lot of couples slide which is they
just slip from one relationship moment
to the next so for example
you know you and i have been dating for
six months my lease is up and i say hey
chris should i renew my my lease or not
you're like that'd be good to split rent
why don't you move in we didn't talk
about what does moving in mean to me
does it mean we're on our way to get
engaged doesn't mean we're going to
figure out if we're good partners maybe
it means nothing but
what other couples do is they decide
they sit down and they actually have a
conversation explicitly about what this
milestone means and so they might say
moving into me means we are engaged to
be engaged and the other person might
say moving into me just means we're
going to spend more time together and
then they might say okay we're not on
the same page let's actually wait until
we are and the research shows that
couples who decide
have healthier relationships they have
more passion they have better sex
they're more likely to survive through
the long haul and so in this theme of
intentional dating or intentional love
deciding is the intentional way to make
major relationship milestone decisions
that was the sense that i had in my mind
this tension between like it being
natural and spontaneous and emergent
and it being i know i don't know what
people i
there is almost everybody that's
listening to this will be intentional
with everything that they do right
they'll eat intentionally they'll sleep
intentionally they'll know the
temperature of the air conditioning that
they go to sleep in if they're in a warm
country or whatever and so like it's
probably not but that like more artistic
view of things that does take things and
then separate it out step by step you
think well
i don't know that
that to me seems like the smart thing to
do
is is there any tension between that and
and sort of romance and spontaneity can
you see a world in which someone sort of
overshoots with regards to their
intentionality
i can definitely see that and you know
we talked a little bit about the
secretary problem in the 37 and i really
see clients and i see emails that say
okay logan so i'm this old and i've
dated this many people and this is my
benchmark person but they rejected me
does that make them my benchmark person
there can definitely be a feeling of i
want to have ultimate control over this
and if i have enough spreadsheets and
enough format conditioning then
everything will work out and so i do
think that there's pushing this too far
so instead how can you think about this
as a layer upon which you view the world
versus a just like every single decision
that you make and so what this might
look like is someone's gonna say
being intentional about love to me is
going to therapy to own my past trauma
and drama
having a rough sense of what i'm looking
for
going on dates where i'm open-minded and
i understand oh i don't actually like
this person i'm just excited because
they don't like me and i want to have
the chase having open conversations from
the beginning about who i am what i'm
looking for and then as you go through
the different phases saying
what does defining the relationship mean
to you
should we move in together should we
get engaged so it's some key moments but
other than that add in as much
spontaneity as you want surprise that
person
take them on a getaway like there's lots
of ways to be romantic in the day-to-day
i just don't want you to miss these big
moments because that's when people make
the big mistakes
talking about
on the other side of relationships how
should people know whether or not they
can
can or should break up with their
partner
yeah you know when i set out to do this
work i certainly never thought that i
would be
talking to people about breakups but
it's become a passion of mine in terms
of the unique research that i've done
and i do have a lot of conversations
with people where they say should i stay
or should i go
and so i have a few practices that i
walk them through so one is kind of
going off the same theme saying what's
your historical tendency do you tend to
be a hitcher someone who stays in
relationships way too long past the
expiration date do you tend to be a
ditcher a person who stays in
relationships way too short always
hopping from
new relationship energy to the next
honeymoon phase things like that so we
talk about that we talk about what are
you bringing to the relationship are you
bringing your best self have you told
the other person how you feel or do you
just expect them to magically know what
you want
and then are there external factors did
one of you lose a job who's a parent is
somebody going through mental health
stuff like is this a temporary moment in
time where things could get better and
then i asked them this final question
which is kind of silly but in this fun
abstract way where i say
it's called the wardrobe test and i say
if your partner wear a piece of clothing
in your closet something that you own
what would they be
and sometimes people say my boyfriend is
a wool sweater he keeps me warm but it's
itchy so i have to take it off or
my boyfriend is
on
ratty t-shirt that i would wear to the
gym but i wouldn't want anyone to see me
in and these are real answers that
people have given me i'm like okay
listen to yourself that's how you
actually feel taking yourself out of
your super rational brain into your
emotions how you feel is that you've
outgrown this relationship or that
something feels off and then we work on
helping them make a plan to leave some
people say lovely things like
my girlfriend is my favorite pair of
pants that i would never have bought for
myself but
make me feel attractive and fun and so i
like the wardrobe test question because
you can make a million pro con lists but
sometimes you just have to get in touch
with how you're actually feeling
what the
hitcher and ditcher is such a good
way to kind of split groups up i think
pretty much everybody that i know falls
into one of those two categories what is
the
typical piece of advice or the first few
pieces of advice that you give to each
person from that group to overcome it
yeah and i would say you know
i do have a lot of frameworks and terms
some will resonate with some people some
won't i think there are people that are
not historically ditchers they leave the
relationship at the appropriate time but
let's say most people are for the
hitchers a lot of them is understanding
this concept of sunk cost fallacy so i'm
sure you know this from economics but if
you spent twenty dollars on a concert
ticket and then you're deciding if you
should go or not you might say oh i
should go because i spent the twenty
dollars it's like you spent the twenty
dollars regardless it doesn't impact the
money if you go and so this idea of when
you made a decision um you throw good
money after bad and you keep feeling
like you have to double down on it when
maybe you can just say i'm gonna cut my
losses twenty dollars i'm not gonna go
to the concert and so they feel like
i've been dating this person for so long
i have to keep going that's not
necessarily true maybe you should have
left the relationship years ago and
maybe this is a great quality you're
very loyal you believe that people can
change but you might need a
readjustment
for ditchers and i do think this is
highly tied to the
avoidant attachment style there's a
feeling of
wait it doesn't feel like it did at the
beginning in the beginning i was
thinking about that person all the time
and
it was so exciting and this and that and
then they just feel like they want to
move on to the next thing and so this is
a lot of work where i do with people
where i help them understand
love is a drug
when you do brain scans of people who
are falling in love it literally lights
up part of their brains that are lit up
when they do
you know drugs like cocaine and so
you're saying quit the relationship and
start a cocaine habit i'm saying you
already have a cocaine habit and the the
cocaine is the love and so understand
that yeah you are in this different
place and your brain is being stimulated
but that doesn't last forever and it's
probably a good thing and so there is
going to be this transition from falling
in love to being in love and if you just
want to spend your whole life falling in
love and there are people like that you
can do it but if you want to be
in a long-term relationship get married
be a dad whatever it is you're gonna
have to accept that the falling will
feel different from the being and how
can we make you excited about the being
and i've spoken to a lot of men who
really successful i really respect and
they talk about how much they love being
married and they're like
your partner is this closet where you're
hanging these different stories and
parts of yourself and memories and this
person has been with you through all of
life and you get to have that partner
and that that is really beautiful and
sure like seducing someone or those
honeymoon period feelings are really
good but if you want to move from
the honeymoon stage to the being in love
stage you do have to have different
expectations for what that feels like
i read a while ago that there's two
attraction systems is it the
passionate and the companionate system
have you heard these before
vaguely but i'm not super knowledgeable
about them there's a lot of frameworks
that are like three different types of
love and stuff like that but not i don't
have expertise in it it just matches
onto what you're saying here that you
kind of have the
i don't know that first period that
pretty much everybody is is familiar
with and then when that begins to wane a
little bit and it becomes much more of a
a friendship a deep friendship with
benefits and love as opposed to the sort
of head-over-heels obsession that occurs
in the first instance
that kind of ties into the spark thing
as well right that that's how it should
feel all the time and i think yeah
that's that's probably pretty erroneous
so let's say that someone's got
themselves to the stage where they know
that the relationship isn't for them
what do you advise people to do if they
need to actually pull the pin and get
themselves out of a relationship you
know so interesting someone might ask me
like what's
what are some of the most meaningful
moments in your work and you might think
i would say like oh when i introduce
this couple or help this person notice
red flags but
the things that really stick out to me
are helping people get out of
relationships that are no longer serving
them because sometimes you really need a
push or a partner or a plan and so i
approach breakups like
the way that i would approach goal
setting and i use goal setting research
and so when i help people plan their
breakup we talk about things like okay
when are you going to do this let's
create a deadline
let's talk about what you're going to
say what your main messages are let's
talk about how you should not have sex
afterwards because that will just be
confusing for both of you
um
there's
even conversations around things like
when are you going to be in touch with
them how long should the conversation be
what are you going to do to make
yourself feel better afterwards how can
you avoid being the nice breakup person
who thinks it's nice to check in with
them all the time but actually you're
confusing them and so we really just
take the very messy
heartbreaking
effort of decoupling and we turn it into
a plan that is compassionate to them and
compassion to the other person and then
i help them execute it and stick to
their goal of being broken up what about
overcoming heartbreak
yeah you know breakups we just talked
about this but if love is a drug then
breaking up with someone often feels
like withdrawal and there's lots of
evidence that it's physically
painful
that you are you perform worse on
cognitive tests people are actually more
likely to commit crimes there's some
really interesting research on how
challenging it is to actually navigate a
breakup and so for anyone listening i
would just say
give yourself a beat this is hard there
are activities that you can do so
there's great research from
gary lewandowski who talks about
rediscover yourself activities so what
are the things in your relationship that
you didn't really pursue because your
partner didn't like them so if you
love going to the beach but your partner
was pale skinned maybe you haven't been
if you love jazz and your partner hated
it you weren't going to jazz shows go do
more of those rediscover yourself
activities and those people seem to
move on from breakups and feel happier
than people who just go out there and do
kind of like generic activities like
going for a walk or spending time with
friends you can also do a lot of
journaling to sort of help your brain
get through the breakup faster so you
can make lists of all the bad qualities
about the person you can make a list of
all the parts of the relationship that
were bad and you're basically thinking
about your brain as this rationalization
monster and how do you feed the monster
by saying oh yeah he was rude to my
sister oh yeah she never did pick me up
from the airport that time and so you're
actually helping yourself remember why
it wasn't as great as you might be
thinking and then there's also this
expression time heals all wounds
well i think the
updated version is that meaning heals
all wounds and you can really
apply meaning to it by saying
what did i learn how will i be different
next time who should i go for in the
future and so really not just assuming
that time will make things better but by
really creating a story of this was an
experience i am better for it i am more
informed in the future and i will move
on logan yuri ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with what
you're doing where should they go
yes people can follow me on instagram
and twitter at loganuri people can learn
more about my class date smarter at
loganuri.com i have a weekly newsletter
they can find out there
and in general people can
listen to my book how to not die alone
or pick it up wherever great books are
sold i really appreciate you i
appreciate your work i think it's very
interesting to look at dating from a
much more scientific background and then
also to have all the data that you get
from hinge so i'm looking forward to
seeing what you come up with over the
next few years as well
thank you so much you were so well
researched great questions i loved our
conversation see you later what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you